une année singulière pour le salon
histoire de lire de versailles pour
maintenir au maximum des moments
d'échangé de partage entre les auteurs
et leurs publics le matériel a dû être
adapté c'est donc un format entièrement
digitale qui a été mise en place
alain juppé auteur de mon chirac ouvrage
récapitulant la longue histoire
politique entre les deux hommes a
participé à cette édition 2020 je suis
très soir participer même si 7digital à
celui de l'adversaire je connais aussi
le rayonnement j'aurais surtout souhaité
que le projet qui ne connaissent pas
d'avoir de lui une image un peu
différents officiels pas toujours
bienveillants et parfois un peu
caricaturale les débats avec les
écrivains sont en direct sur les réseaux
et les livres dédicacés peuvent être
commandées avant et pendant le live un
contact minime entre l'auteur et son
public qui change de l'habituel c'est
important parce que c'est l'occasion
d'établir évidemment un contact
personnel avec un électeur toujours le
temps de discuter longuement hausse il
ya une file la personne l'idée de se
faire dédicacer leurs ouvrages mais ben
non pas une phrase regard c'est déjà
quelque chose qui crée du lien que
lecteur je crois que c'est très
important
respectons tous les mesures de
confinement mais est plus artificielles
une alternative que les écrivains adopte
en espérant qu'elle soit de courte durée
supporte la situation n'a pas d'autre
solution et que le vaccin va arriver
malgré ces conditions bien particulières
les conférences ont lieu tous les jours
jusqu'au 28 novembre le salon d'histoire
de l'irs a également maintenu le prix
décernés aux meilleurs youtuber
d'histoire pour mettre en avant la
jeunesse et le digital